am Samstag hielt die Welt den Atem an
und blickte nach Moskau denn für einige
Stunden saß nach einem Putsch gegen
Putin aus ja nach Bürgerkrieg der Chef
der berüchtigten Söldnertruppe Wagner
prigoshi in ließ seine Truppen gern
moskam marschieren und machte erst gut
200 km vor den Toren des kremlight nach
anfänglichen machtvollen Drogen Putins
in Richtung des abtrünnigen Vasallen
dann am Abend der Deal mit ihm freies
Geleit Richtung Bella Ross der Kutsch
war verhindert unblutig aber mit
Gesichtsverlust Putins was sagt dieser
unvollendete Putsch über die
Machtverhältnisse in Russland aus was
bedeutet er für den Krieg in der Ukraine
und wie muss sich der Westen jetzt
verhalten mit diesen Fragen begrüße ich
Sie sehr herzlich bei Unter den Linden
[Musik]
und bei uns im Studio begrüße ich sehr
herzlich Dietmar Bartsch den
Fraktionsvorsitzenden von DIE LINKE im
Deutschen Bundestag und ich begrüße
ebenfalls sehr herzlich Jürgen hart den
außenpolitischen Sprecher der
cdu/csu-fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag
und uns heute zugeschaltet aus
Düsseldorf herzlich Willkommen an sie
beide guten Abend guten Abend
nachdem wir einige stundentage von
Jewgeni progoschi nichts gehört haben
prigoshi nichts gehört haben heute abend
nun die audiobootschaft es wäre kein
Putsch gegen Putin gewesen sondern es
wäre ihm vor allen Dingen um die Rettung
seiner Truppen gegangen und er sprach
sogar von einem Maß der Gerechten die
glaubwürdig ist das
also ich glaube dass man aktuell nicht
so viel für bare Münze nehmen sollte
mich würde schon interessieren wo dann
das aufgenommen worden ist ob vielleicht
dahinter drei Maschinengewehre waren
oder oder also mich stören all
diejenigen die genau wissen was da
passiert ist aber eins ist klar das
haben sie sehr deutlichen Anmoderation
gesagt ist auf jeden Fall eine
Schwächung Putins das kann man so
konstatieren denn das was da passiert
ist ist auf jeden Fall nicht normal
nicht rational nachvollziehbar und die
Folgen werden wir in einigen Wochen
erfahren ob der nun glaubwürdig ist oder
nicht das will ich mal einen Zweifel
Stellen auf jeden Fall ist er einer
derjenigen denn wirklich für unzählige
Verbrechen verantwortlich ist nicht nur
in der Ukraine sondern in vielen Ländern
dieser Erde
er hat auch die Frage an Sie die audiobo
Botschaft von
ähm wie glaubwürdig für die glaubwürdig
halten die die das ist tatsächlich sich
nicht um einen Putsch gegen Putin
gehandelt habe
also wir wissen natürlich noch nicht
alles über diese Situation der letzten
Tage aber nach meiner Einschätzung ist
ja der Konflikt eskaliert zwischen der
militärischen Führung der russischen
Streitkräfte aus Minister Scholl GU in
dem generalstoffchef und eben brigochien
und den Wagner Leuten und es hat immer
über die letzten Monate wechselseitige
Schuldzuweisungen gegeben für
Misserfolge im Kampf gegen die Ukraine
und es hat eben vor wenigen Tagen eine
Anordnung gegeben dass die Wagner
Söldner sich bis Ende Juli glaube ich
eintragen sollen in den Listen der
regulären Streitkräfte damit war für
prigosh ihn klar wenn das Okay käme wäre
nicht nur sein Geschäftsmodell
Söldnerführer zu sein sondern auch seine
Macht Basis weg und ich glaube er hat
einfach die Flucht nach vorne gesucht
und hat gedacht wenn ich mit den vielen
unzufriedenen Wagner sollten dann und
den vielen unzufriedenen russischen
Soldaten die ja auch merken dass dieser
Krieg nicht vorankommt in ihrem Sinne
Richtung Moskauer Schere werden sich
andere mich mir anschließen und werden
wir Druck aufbauen können in Moskau und
verhandeln können über die Zukunft das
hat sich so nicht bewahrheitet
offensichtlich haben sich keine
regulären Truppen angeschlossen diesen
diesen marschken Moskau und dann hat
pregorian dem letzten Augenblick die
Notbremse gezogen aber sich damit rettet
im physischen Sinne weiß ich nicht aber
die fragen wie es mit Wagner und ihm
weitergeht sind natürlich jetzt total
offen ja am Samstag diese Nachrichten
hörten was ging ihnen da durch den Kopf
eine Chance für den Frieden oder dass da
eher ein Sturz ins Chaos droht also
weiteres hielt ich für wahrscheinlicher
also ich habe ja schon vor vielen Jahren
damals ein Putsch gegen Gorbatschow
erleben dürfen war dabei als gegen
Erdogan in der Türkei geputzt worden ist
wie das einzuschätzen war da habe ich
vor allen Dingen Fragezeichen gehabt
mich hat ein bisschen gewundert werde
alle ist genau wusste und ich fand
wirklich angemessen dass die
Staatenlenker also Amerikas beiden
Scholz
macron und so weiter dass die erstmal
ihre Einschätzung sehr zurückhaltend
waren das war richtig und all diejenigen
die genau wissen was da passiert man
sollte sehr vorsichtig sein dann habe
ich danach gehört dass alles Fake
gewesen und von Putin organisiert da
glaube ich natürlich auch keine Sekunde
dran aber vor allen Dingen habe ich
Sorge gehabt denn eins ist klar wenn
jemand wie brigoche ihn oder ein anderer
das sagen hätte in Russland das ist
nicht unbedingt eine Garantie dass der
Krieg schnell zu Ende ist sondern es
gibt ja sehr viel Kritik dass man alle
Möglichkeiten ausschöpfen sollte was
irre ist deswegen also wir können ja nur
das Ziel haben das genau solche Leute
wie der brigori nicht das Sagen bekommen
aber selbstverständlich muss das oberste
Ziel seine Krieg zu beenden ob das mit
dem näher waren da habe ich zweifel ich
glaube eher dass auch dieser Putsch
nicht dazu führt dass es an der Front
und da sagen ja alle Nachrichten der
Stunden danach und auch der Tage danach
dass er die Aggressivität auch Russland
gestiegen ist man sieht das bei Raketen
man sieht das bei Bomber der Magens auch
auf Odessa das ist also eher eine
angespannte Situation mir hat das große
Sorgen bereitet große Sorgen bereitet
weil jegliche Eskalation und jegliche
Unkalkulierbarkeit ist ein Problem nicht
nur für Russland sondern auch für den
Krieg Russland Ukraine aber auch darüber
hinaus zu den Folgen kommen wir
natürlich gleich noch ausführlicher er
hat
progoschin und und seine Söldnertruppe
die haben ja einen ein Ruf oder wenn man
sagen mit Blick auf auf Syrien Mali
Ukraine und so weiter kann man
wahrscheinlich auch sagen dass es sich
darum Massenmörder handelt war er für
sie an dem Samstag so eine Art
kurzzeitiger Hoffnungsträger weil es
gegen Putin ging oder wie war ihre
Einschätzung
meine erste Reaktion war ich habe genau
die Frage mir jetzt auch vorgelegt meine
erste Reaktion war das zunächst mal die
der russische Angriff gegen die Ukraine
natürlich dadurch geschwächt wird nasse
fehlen jetzt die Wagner Söldner die
waren äußerst brutal rücksichtslos gegen
andere aber vermutlich auch gegen sich
selbst Menschen die nichts zu verlieren
haben teilweise ja ehemalige
Strafgefangene allesamt Menschen die
wissen dass sie Kriegsverbrechen
begangen haben für die sie ansonsten mal
zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden könnten
wenn dieser Krieg zu ihren Ungunsten
ausgeht und wenn die raus sind aus dem
Gefechtsfeld und sich Richtung Moskau
bewegen dann ist das zunächst meine
Entlastung für die Ukraine das war mein
erster Gedanke mein zweiter Gedanke war
das ja eigentlich wenn es also eine Art
Putsch sein sollte nicht zu erwarten ist
dass sich reguläre russische generale
jetzt ausgerechnet einen putscht von
Herrn brigochien anschließen also die
würden dann sagen selbst wenn sie die
Idee hätten dass das vielleicht auch
eine Option für sie ist würden Sie sagen
dann machen wir das lieber selbst dass
wir diesen
Söldnerführer folgen und mein dritter
Gedanke war was bedeutet das für Wagner
überhaupt Wagner sie haben es ja
angesprochen es in vielen Teilen der
Welt aktiv konkret in Mali die Truppe
die gegenwärtig die malische Regierung
stützt diejenige die uns rausschmeißen
will aus dem Land die das Ur in Mandat
nicht verlängert haben will weil sie
eben nach der Pfeife putinstanzen aus
welchen Gründen auch immer darüber kann
ich auch nur mutmaßen Max sich jeder
selbst seine Gedanken machen und die
Wagner Söldner sind eben die
militärische Stütze dieser politischen
Führung in Mali dieser Militär herunter
die dort regiert und wenn jetzt konkrete
Wagner geschwächt ist und vielleicht
kein Geld mehr aus Moskau bekommt dann
werden diese sollten auch nicht weiter
kämpfen und da wird sich auch die
Situation im Mali ändern deswegen glaube
ich dass wir prüfen müssen ob denn im
Blick auf das Zurückdrängen russischen
Einfluss ist in Afrika dort wo die
unschwierigkeiten mit Russland hat wir
vielleicht da eine Chance sehen aber das
ist zu früh das im Einzelnen zu bewerten
nur diesen Blick finde ich sollten wir
auch haben
sprach ja gegenüber prigoshi von einem
Verräter und trotzdem hat es nach dem
Rückzug der Truppen tatsächlich freies
Geleit für ihn gegeben oder zumindest
ist es ihm versprochen worden ob das
letztendlich wirklich ein freies Geleit
wird ist ja noch noch offen aber hat
Putin da nicht auch ein Stück sein
Gesicht verloren ja natürlich also wenn
jemand geschwächt ist dann ist das Putin
wenn es irgendwann mal ein Zeitpunkt
geben wird wo man schaut wann war der
Anfang vom Ende wird das vielleicht
genau dieser Tag sein weil alle haben
gesehen das tut Ihnen innerhalb von
Stunden seine Meinung geändert hat erst
Verrat dann frei ist Geleit jetzt gibt's
dieses telegram-video also man weiß im
Moment noch nicht was ist aber fakt ist
wenn man von Verrat spricht von Deutsch
Stoß und ähnliches was tut ihnen ja an
einer Fernsehansprache gemacht hat dann
ist das nicht wohlkalkuliert das zeigt
die Schwäche das zeigt mehr als Risse in
dem System und das ist das was man
konstatieren muss das ist eine
Schwächung dort gibt und das ist
offensichtlich in der russische
Auseinandersetzung gibt interessant ist
ja auch dass der Verteidigungsminister
showigu bisher danach noch nicht
sichtbar ist und auch bei vielen
Generalen ist nicht klar
und man weiß im Moment vieles nicht man
sieht das in der an der Front wenig
Bewegung ist aber es gibt im Moment
vieles was ungeklärt ist man muss immer
auch im Blick haben also formal wird es
ja im nächsten Jahr in Russland Wahlen
geben und Putin will sich nach allem was
man weiß ja wieder zur Wahl stellen ich
meine das muss man alles mit im Blick
haben und auch das was real passiert ist
eine völlig unübersichtliche Situation
und eines da hat recht es ist nicht so
gewesen dass etwa reguläre Truppen oder
wirklich Menschen in Größenordnung sich
jetzt dem angeschlossen hätten das ist
nicht der Fall gewesen und das ist auch
eine Aussage deswegen teile ich alle die
Position die da sagen lass uns mal
schauen was real passiert was wird auch
weiter passieren ich meine das jetzt der
Lukas Risiko gelobt wird das sagt ja
auch so viel das ist ja jemand der nur
auch sein Land mit hartem Terror
unterdrückt und jetzt sozusagen gelobt
wird von brigoshi das ist alles irre das
ist alles irre und deshalb das richtige
Maß an Zurückhaltung natürlich der Blick
auf den Krieg in der Ukraine aber das
ist jetzt sofort Schlussfolgerung gibt
wir müssen das oder jenes tun ich sehe
das auch so dass damit auch Wagner
natürlich geschwächt sein wird ob der
Russland jemals verlässt das ist eine
große Frage und sowohl Syrien als auch
Mali als auch andere afrikanische
Staaten oder er für Geld agiert und wenn
man das richtig weiß ich weiß nicht ob
das stimmt aber zumindest wurde das in
Medien berichtet dass er auch angeboten
hat in bachmut dass er mit der Ukraine
ein Deal macht das ist ja alles eine
irre Situation jemand der im Kern
Milliardär ist und der letztlich kriegt
zum Geschäft macht er ist für mich der
allerletzte wenn irgendeiner Weise aber
da sind wir uns ja auch einig in
irgendeiner Weise Unterstützung verdient
also auf gar keinen Fall es würde gerne
noch mal so kurz darauf kommen auf die
Risse die sich in diesem System Putin
vielleicht auch zeigen brigorstein hat
ja für den Grund seines Aufbegehrens
mehrere Gründe genannt er hat ja gesagt
die fehlende Munition das Versagen der
russischen Militärführung die Tatsache
dass er sich nun wir hat ja auch schon
angedeutet und angesagt hat dass er sich
der russischen Armee hätte unterstellen
müssen und so weiter außerdem hat er
aber auf Telegramm davon gesprochen der
Ukraine kriegst ja nur begonnen worden
um eine Clique um Putin herumgeltung zu
verschaffen das ist ja ein neues
narrativ was er da ähm erwähnt wie
schwach ist Putin in den eigentlich dass
er sich so etwas überhaupt gefallen ist
ja gut das sagt ja ganz viel wenn der
das sagen darf und danach frei ist Leid
hat wenn er die Kriegsziele die Putin ja
in Russland verkündet der hat ja
weiterhin der spricht ja gar nicht vom
Krieg ist aber nicht vergessen der
erzählt dass er in der Ukraine befreit
der spricht von den vielen die aus der
Ukraine nach Russland oder in die
annektierten Gebiete geflüchtet sind das
ist ja sozusagen sein narrativ dass er
Menschen befreit und das ist natürlich
jetzt völlig konterkariert worden
deswegen zunächst Verrat und plötzlich
ist es aber kein Verrat mehr das sagt ja
es ist gibt eine eklatante Schwäche wenn
man das so zulässt natürlich gibt es da
viele Ursachen also die
Wagner Söldner werden ja ganz anders
bezahlt als die reguläre russische Armee
natürlich werden nur wenige für einen
ganz anderen soll sich eingliedern
lassen natürlich ist es so dass bei den
Wagner Sölden dann eben vielfach auch
Russen dabei sind was ja sonst bei den
regulären Truppen die an der Front sind
weniger der Fall ist also viele Faktoren
die da eine Rolle spielen aber auch die
Tatsache dass es zu wenig Munition gibt
dass der dann offensichtlich und das ist
ja auch eine Aussage
Lage angelegt hat in Russland wovon im
übrigen der deutsche Geheimdienst
offensichtlich nicht wusste ein Glück
dass wir die Amerikaner haben die da
wenigstens so halbwegs eine Übersicht
haben also es kein guter Tag für ein
Carl finde ich jedenfalls aber dass das
alles so vorbereitet werden konnte das
sagt ganz viel und das ist nicht ein
Zeichen von Stärke und dieses was viele
ja sagen man darf Putin nicht auf die
Spitze reizen weil Atomwaffen Raketen
Silos in Sibirien und und und das stimmt
alles und ich bin dafür dass wir
weiterhin alles versuchen dass es
möglichst schnell Frieden in der Ukraine
gibt aber die Schwäche Putins die ist
eklatant und ich sag noch mal das war
der Anfang vom Ende er hat da würde ich
gerne bei Ihnen auch noch mal nachfragen
bleiben wenn man ein bisschen bei den
Rissen der Bart spricht sogar vom Anfang
vom Ende freies Geleit ist das eine neue
narrativ für den Beginn des Krieges ist
etwas was bedeutet denn diese Risse die
da sehr deutlich werden denn auch für
den unmittelbaren Zirkel mit dem Putin
sich umgibt von Oligarchen und von
anderen mächtigen in das Landes
ich glaube dass er komplett
abgeschirmtes von den bewahren
Informationen dass er selbst auch
diese Legenden teilweise glaubt die er
verbreitet für mich ist der 24 Februar
22 der Anfang das Anfang von Ende Putins
ich habe das damals auch so gesagt dabei
bleibe ich auch weil im Grunde seitdem
ihm fast alles misslungen ist was er
angepackt hat leider leiden wir alle
sehr darunter aber es ist ja keine
seiner Kriegsziel erreicht und was
passiert ist am Wochenende zum ersten
Mal hat die russische Öffentlichkeit
gespürt dass dieser Krieg tatsächlich
auch Russland erfassen kann zum ersten
Mal haben die Menschen in Moskau z.B die
Flüge aus Moskau raus am Samstag und
Sonntag waren ausgebucht haben die
Menschen gemerkt so nach dem Motto was
wäre wenn hier irgendwas schief läuft
vielleicht doch ganz anders läuft als
wir das erzählt bekommen und eine
Legende die Protein da aufgebaut hat ist
vermutlich in der nächsten Zeit nicht
mehr so aufrecht zu halten und das ist
allerdings auch ein Risiko denn
eine Möglichkeit für putinen aus der
Nummer rauszukommen aus diesem
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg und
seine Erfolglosigkeit wäre ja dass er
eines Tages einfach erklärt der Krieg
ist gewonnen ich stelle jetzt die
krampfhandlungen ein es gibt keine
Faschisten mehr in der Ukraine wir
verhandeln jetzt das narrativ dass er
der Sieger oder dass er der erfolgreiche
ist in diesem Kampf ist umso schwieriger
jetzt aufrecht zu unterhalten wo das was
brigos hin gesagt hat in der Welt ist wo
das was die Wagner Leute gesagt haben in
der Welt ist und das Problem mit Wagner
ist natürlich auch für Putin ein anderes
es gibt jetzt tausende von sozusagen
Arbeitslosen den Arbeitslosen Profi
Kieler möchte ich sagen
Soldaten sollte man die Person gar nicht
nennen weil man das denn Soldaten Beruf
den Anstand der Soldat an den Tag zu
legen hat bei denen ja vermissen muss
die Frage ist was machen die wenn die
arbeitslos sind von wem lassen die sich
anhören lassen die sich von irgendeinem
Provinzfürsten in der in der in der
Russischen Föderation anhäufen der jetzt
jetzt ist die Gelegenheit gekommen mich
unabhängig zu machen von Moskau wo
Moskau schwach ist ich glaube dass die
Bedrohung für Putin tatsächlich aus dem
Inneren kommen kann und dass er noch
lange nicht an diesem Punkt vorbei ist
es gibt die Aufforderung an diese
wagner-kämpfer sich jetzt den regulären
Streitkräften anzuschließen es wurde
aber zugesagt die die mit auf bei dem
Marsch Richtung Moskau dabei waren die
würden nicht in die regulären
Streitkräfte aufgenommen ja was machen
die mit ihren Waffen was machen die mit
ihrer überschüssigen Kraft das ist wie
in 30-jährigen Krieg der Krieg ernährt
seine seine Soldaten und die Frage ist
wo wenden die sich hin und was machen
die deswegen ist es auch gut dass wir
als NATO gerade im Baltikum auch
aufmerksam sind denn wenn da Wagner
sollten etwas Russland in großer Zahl
unterwegs sind dann muss die Grenze dann
Außengrenze der NATO gut geschützt sein
wenn sie von der Bedrohung aus dem
Inneren sprechen meinen sie damit zum
Beispiel die Wagner Söldner oder meinen
Sie auch das unmittelbare Umfeld von von
Putin also im unmittelbaren Umfeld
glaube ich ist natürlich diejenigen die
von diesem System Putin profitieren sich
die Frage stellen was passiert wenn das
System kollabiert und dann
möglicherweise zu dem Ergebnis kommen
könnten wenn sie einen also eine eine
Schein Revolution eine
scheinpalastrevolution durchführen gar
nicht mit der Absicht an den politischen
Verhältnissen irgendwas zu ändern außer
eben Personen auszuwechseln zum Beispiel
Putin selbst auszuwechseln um sozusagen
das System an sich zu erhalten das ja in
der russischen Bevölkerung nicht so
umstritten ist wie wir uns das wünschen
und wie das wäre wenn es freie
Meinungsäußerungen im Lande gäbe dass
die vielleicht auf die Idee kommen
irgendwann zu sagen das war alles Putin
putin ist derjenige der hier seine
präsidialen Befugnisse weit überzogen
hat er ist der Kriegsverbrecher den
stecken wir in die Bianca und jetzt
fangen wir sozusagen an dem Punkt vor
dem 24 Februar neu an vor dem 24 Februar
letzten Jahres neu an und der Erwartung
vom Westen dass er uns das ein Stück
weit abnimmt dass wir Putin sozusagen
verantwortlich machen aber auch das wird
jetzt schwieriger mehr durch bregoschin
die Wahrheit jetzt auch mal von einem
der beteiligten ausgesprochen worden ist
nicht nur von westlichen Medien oder von
der ukrainischen Regierung sondern
privatin hat ja eins zu eins das gesagt
was wir über diesen Krieg wissen das ist
eben ein riesen Fake ist dass es hier
gegen NATO oder Faschisten in der
Ukraine geht sondern das ist ein
völkerhitzwidriger Angriffskrieg ist ich
darf man eine Sache vielleicht
widersprechen eine Art und zwar was die
russische Bevölkerung und die
Widerspiegelung betrifft also wir dürfen
überhaupt nicht unterschätzen dass in
Russland die Propaganda die aus Russland
kommt dazu führt dass sie Unterstützung
für Putin vergleichsweise großes auch
nach dem Sonntag das ist ja die Wahrheit
also ich finde das auch eher
problematisch aber es gibt eben gar
keine andere Medien und es gibt nur die
berieslung aus einer Richtung und das
führt natürlich dazu dass das eine
relativ was Putin und was andere dort in
Russland verbreiten dort mehrheitlich
angenommen werden wird deshalb gibt's
diese große Unterstützung ich glaube das
ist ein Problem ist und Sie haben recht
wenn aus dem engeren oligarchenzirkel
das kann man sich nur wünschen aber ich
würde da die These vertreten das ist bei
uns Wunsch aktuell ist es leider so dass
die Unterstützung weiterhin groß ist
weil genau dieses narrativ also damals
haben unsere Großväter im Großen
Vaterländischen Krieg gekämpft und so
weiter also mir muss niemand sagen dass
das Unsinn ist aber das funktioniert und
wer einmal russische Sender sich
anschaut und dort nur einen Tag mitnimmt
da weiß man in etwa wie das ist wenn man
das nur hat weil da wäre natürlich
Logiken aufgebaut die alle nicht völlig
abwegig sind und das funktioniert
richtig ist und das ist ja der ist
Ereignis des Sonntags das mit rigor
Jeans agieren das alles in Frage
gestellt worden ist weil ein Oligarch
der selbst vielfacher Milliardär ist
dessen Kinder übrigens genauso
privilegiert sind wie andere von
Oligarchen dass der Dinge ausspricht die
ansonsten den Westen zugeschrieben
werden das ist eine neue Qualität
inwieweit das wirklich jetzt Russland
erfasst klar der hat bei telegram
vergleichsweise viele Abonnenten aber ob
das wirklich Russland erfasst dass es
glaube ich eine große Frage und deswegen
müssen all diese Aspekte wohl beleuchtet
werden und vor allen Dingen bleibt ja
völlig unabhängig davon der Krieg in der
Ukraine der ist völlig ungebrochen läuft
der weiter und das ist unsere zentrale
Aufgabe natürlich würde ich mir wünschen
dass in Russland wirklich die russische
Bevölkerung frei entscheiden kann und
wirklich zu einem Land wird wo das
Potenzial was dort ist wirklich genutzt
wird weil ich sehe ja mit einiger Sorge
wie die Entwicklung ist und dass die
Russen in alle so sind und so weiter das
finde ich alles furchtbar als jemand der
da einige Jahre auch gelebt hat und da
müssen wir gemeinsam glaube ich dahin
wirken dass Russland eine Chance hat
gerade wir als Deutsche wir haben da
auch eine besondere Verantwortung ja das
war ja immer die Rede davon dass das
System Putin eigentlich nur von innen
heraus implodieren kann würden Sie sagen
der Zeitpunkt ist da jetzt gekommen
also zunächst einmal glaube ich kein
Widerspruch zu sehen zwischen dem was
ich vorhin gesagt habe und was erwartet
gesagt hat auch ich glaube
das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich ist dass
es zu einem Art Mai dann Erlebnis oder
wie das in Minsk August 20 gewesen ist
in Russland in Kürze kommt ich glaube
wenn es eine
eine Veränderung gibt dann eben eine
Palastrevolution aber nicht mit dem Ziel
jetzt das Land komplett zu verändern
sondern dieses Machtsystem was Putin ja
geschaffen hat zu erhalten obwohl es
durch Putins Handeln jetzt in Gefahr
geraten ist was ja am vergangene
Wochenende offensichtlich wurde ich
glaube dass wir dass wir da sehr
vorsichtig sein müssen mit Erwartungen
ich glaube das Beste was wir tun können
ist dass wir die Ukraine dabei
unterstützen diesen Krieg zu gewinnen
denn in dem Augenblick wo in Moskau klar
wird dass dieser Krieg von Russland
nicht gewonnen ist sondern verloren ist
und z.B die Ostukraine oder gar die
Grimm aus russischer Sicht verloren geht
also die Ukraine ihre völkerlich dieses
Tiere Thorium zurückgewinnen kann dann
kann ich mir schon vorstellen dass sie
nicht nur eine Palastrevolution denkbar
ist sondern dass
vielleicht auch die Menschen auf der
Straße anfangen zu zweifeln aber ich
habe überhaupt keinen Einblick in die
Strukturen im Gremmel ich kann ich
glaube wenn das ist die eine Million
Dollar Frage wer ist der potenzielle
Putschist dort auf jeden Fall hat er
sich am vergangenen Wochenende noch
nicht gezeigt ich glaube das können wir
auch als Ergebnis dieses Wochenende sein
können Sie da mehr Licht ins Dunkel
bringen wenn es um die Strukturen aber
die Frage ist wer ist denn unter denen
die sich die dort bei Putin sind
derjenige der den Ton angibt und da gibt
es ja an der ein oder anderen Stelle
vielleicht sogar noch schärferer also
noch größere scharf mache als Putin
selber gut das ist ja auf jeden Fall so
dass es viele gibt die Putin vor allen
Dingen kritisieren weil er diesen Krieg
nicht in Konsequenz führt und die eben
sagen es ist ein Krieg aber Putin
spricht immer noch von der
spezialoperation die auch alles was ein
Krieg ausmacht dann auch fahren wollen
ich glaube dass es eher gefährlich ist
aber also leider kann ich da gar nicht
zu sagen da wäre ich wirklich würdig
wahrscheinlich die eine Millionen Dollar
gewinnen aber ich bewerbe mich gar nicht
dafür dass es nicht der Fall strukturell
ist natürlich eines klar es ist ein
autokratisches System und den
autokratischen Systemen ist es so dass
entweder alles bleibt wenn der Auto
gerade ausgewechselt wird bleibt
strukturell alles aber ich sehe da im
Moment wenig weil wenn man sich das
anschaut in den Provinzen gibt es eine
weitgehende Stabilität das muss mir
einfach sagen es gibt eine weitgehende
Stabilität es werden vor allen Dingen
diejenigen auch eingezogen an die Front
die eben nationalen Minderheiten
angehören wo Jacken aus der Gestagen und
auch
aus den Randgebieten Russlands das ist
die Wahrheit und sind wenige die eben
aus Leningrad aus Moskau aus den großen
Städten gezogen werden und dass das
Problem ist meines Erachtens dass wir
dort auch gegenüber Russland nicht
unbedingt immer die richtige Strategie
haben denn zu glauben wir werden am Ende
militärisch oder die Ukraine wird es
militärisch lösen das ist nicht meine
Position ich glaube das ist auch ein
Stück weit den Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainern wird immer gesagt hat die
wollen alle kämpfen und alles also ich
war unlängst in der Ukraine und es ist
etwas differenzierter wenn man dann dort
im Kugelhagel ist hat man eine andere
Position und unser Ziel muss doch sein
oder Ziel muss sein erstens der Krieg
schnellstmöglich beendet werden
und gleichzeitig also ich nehme jetzt
geh noch mal auf Russland muss natürlich
das Ziel sein dass wir auch Russland
mittelfristig in die Staatengemeinschaft
zurückholen als ein gleichberechtigtes
Land wo die Potenziale genutzt werden
und wo auch die Potenziale der Menschen
in Russland genutzt werden wir dürfen
nicht eine Strategie die auf Ausgrenzung
natürlich mit Putin und diesem
autokratischen system will ich auch
nicht zu tun haben und ich hoffe niemand
aber wir brauchen Russland und die
Menschen dort mittelfristig probiert
der glauben Sie dass wir die nicht
brauchen liebe Herr hart glauben wir
glauben Sie dass wir die Russen
ausgrenzen müssen dauerhaft ich glaube
das nicht ich glaube das Putin die
Russen ausgrenzt und nicht Russland sich
selbst oder wir die Russen ausgrenzen
wir haben über zehn Jahre lang nach
diesem doch üblen völkerrechtswilligen
Angriff auf die Ukraine Besetzung der
Krim und Einmischung oder aus Ukraine 10
Jahre lang verhandelt mit Protein wir
haben viele Runden auch im Übrigen eine
Runde in Berlin wo alle Staats- und
Regierungschefs das noch mal die Formats
zusammen waren also die davon
französische präsidente der Deutsche
Bund die deutsche Bundeskanzlerin der
Präsident der Ukraine und Präsident
Russlands die nachts zusammengeflogen
worden in Berlin weil man gehofft hat
wir kriegen einen Durchbruch hin was die
Lösung des diskrim Konfliktes das aus
kokaine Konfliktes angeht also bevor
dieser Krieg vom 24 Februar 22 ausbrach
da haben wir uns wirklich hinter die
Fichte führen lassen Putin hat die
gesamte Zeit die gesamte 10 Jahre
ist um nichts von den Vereinbarungen von
mindest eins oder mindest zwei
umzusetzen gleichzeitig hat er
aufgerüstet gleichzeitig hat er seine
Streitkräfte weiter ertüchtigt er hat
noch wenige Tage vor dem Angriff auf die
Ukraine sowohl dem deutschen
Bundeskanzler als auch dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten gesagt wir
hätten alle die Paranoia dass wir
glauben würden er wäre aggressiv und
würde da etwas vorbereiten dieser Mann
putin ist kein
gesprächspakzeptabler Gesprächspartner
für die westliche Welt und Verhandlungen
unter Putin wird es nicht geben und wenn
Sie mich fragen auch Russland wird keine
Verhandlung unter Putin führen wollen
warum weil in dem Augenblick wo man in
Moskau zum Ergebnis kommt dass man den
tatsächlicher ernsthafte Verhandlungen
eintreten muss die nicht nur
Diktat Frieden in aus der Sicht eines
Siegers heraus sind dann wird man den
Moskau sehr schnell feststellen dass die
Verhandlungsposition Russland ja
eindeutig besser wäre wenn man die ganze
Schuld und Verantwortung Putin und
vielleicht noch einige wenigen anderen
zuschiebt und die dann in die Bianca
steckt
schon sagt die haben wir selbst hier aus
dem Verkehr gezogen ihr könnt jetzt
nicht Russland für das verantwortlich
machen was die getan haben genau das ist
ja das Problem das Putin das auch weiß
dass er im Falle von ernsthaften
Friedensverhandlungen als russischer
Präsident der diese Verantwortung auf
seinen Schultern hat keine Rolle spielen
wird auch aus russischer Sicht keine
Rolle spielen wird der wird jeden Morgen
aufwachen und froh sein dass er noch
lebt und das ist die Situation die ihm
glaube ich immer klarer wird und er weiß
wenn er diesen Krieg nicht gewinnt wird
es genauso kommen wie ich gerade gesagt
habe und deswegen müssen wir uns noch
auf harte Wochen und Monate einstellen
aber am Ende des Tages muss die Ukraine
an den Punkt Putin und das Regime an dem
Punkt eben bringen dass die Sackgasse
offensichtlich ist unterwegs nicht
weitergeschnitten werden kann und man
umkehrt also wenn ich ich darf immer
zwei Dinge muss ich widersprechen
was die Vergangenheit betrifft so nicht
ich fand und finde ist richtig dass
Angela Merkel zusammen mit dem Manuel
macron versucht hat über Dienst einst -2
wirklich über Verhandlungen zu Lösungen
zu kommen ich weiß Sie haben Recht dass
das nicht erfolgreich war am Ergebnis
und trotzdem bleibe ich dabei das ist
richtig wahr zu verhandeln und es ist im
übrigen falsch Putin hat das nicht
eingehalten richtig aber auch die
Ukraine hat vieles von Minsk nicht
eingehalten das gehört mit zur Wahrheit
lassen Sie mich dazu
also ich sage weiterhin das war
vernünftig ja ich gebe gern zu dass ich
den 24 Februar nicht für möglich
erachtet habe bis eine Woche vorher
hätte ich bei einer gewettet dass das
nicht passieren wird da habe ich mich
ganz gewaltig geirrt und bin da in einer
Reihe mit anderen jetzt ist eine andere
Situation auch das teile ich und
trotzdem müssen wir Perspektive dahin
kommen dass wir mit Russland mit einem
Russland nach Putin selbstverständlich
zusammenarbeiten wollen und müssen das
ist meine feste Überzeugung und das sage
ich gerade also wir haben als deutsche
das Privileg dass man uns nach all den
Verbrechen wieder in die Staaten
Gesellschaft aufgenommen hat und da
können wir dankbar sein und genauso ist
unsere Verantwortung dort alles zu tun
das ist eine Chance gibt dass es mit
Russland nicht heute nicht morgen und
nicht mit Putins Russland das ist dort
eine Zusammenarbeit gibt es meine feste
Überzeugung wir brauchen das und wir
müssen genau das auch den Menschen in
Russland sagen und zeigen denn wenn die
in diese Situation kommen die sie eben
für Putin geschildert haben die wird
dann ganz genau für alle Russinnen und
Russen gelten die werden dann genau
dieses narrativ der große vaterländische
Krieg den werde das wird bedient werden
und natürlich bedienen sie doch jetzt
schon da muss ich doch nur den Lauf
anhören und der erzählt dann dort ja an
unserer Seite stehen so wichtige Länder
wie China wie Südafrika wie Indien
Brasilien und so weiter ich weiß dass
das so nicht ist aber dieses narrativ
wird bedient und deswegen bleibe ich
dabei wenn wir sagen es werden lange und
schwere Wochen ich glaube wir müssen
alles tun dass wir
zufriedensverhandlungen kommen es darf
keinen abnutzungskrieg geben und da auch
danach auch nach diesen Sonntag ist das
Eskalationspotenzial Russland weiterhin
und das sagen alle das wissen Sie wie
ich sagen alle die sich dort ein wenig
auskennen dass es leider immer noch groß
ich bin froh dass die Risse sichtbar
geworden sind ich bin froh dass
vielleicht sogar damit Gespräche
möglicher geworden sind aber es besteht
auch die andere Gefahr die sie gesagt
haben dass im Putin jeden Tag froh ist
den er noch am Leben ist und dass wir
dann wirklich nur von innen heraus zu
einer Lösung kommen können ich finde wir
sollten auf gar keinen Fall also ich
sag's mal andersrum das Wort
friedensverhandlung darf kein tabu-wort
in Deutschland sein
Herr hatte ich würde gerne noch mal ein
Stück weit aufs Hier und Jetzt weil
Friedensverhandlungen sind ja noch nicht
so richtig in greifbarer Nähe schauen
wenn wir uns den Krieg gegen die Ukraine
Anschauen der vom Putin ausgeführt wird
so ist das ja nur ein Teil der von der
russischen Armee dort vollführt wird die
sollte eine Truppe Wagner war zwar die
größte
Söldnertruppe es gibt aber ja mehrere
seltener Truppen und diese
Söldnertruppen sind meistens von
ethnischen Minderheiten der Russischen
Föderation bestückt was für Auswirkungen
hat denn dieser Putschversuch jetzt auch
auf diese anderen ethnischen
Minderheiten und glauben sie dass da
noch mehr hinter stecken könnte dann
vielleicht sogar ein größerer
Putschversuch noch mal mit mehreren
anderen
kommen könnte
also ich glaube wenn Putin die Situation
jetzt sorgfältig analysiert wird er zum
Ergebnis kommen dass der
Verteidigungsminister den Streit mit
Krieg heute in zu weit getrieben hat
also insbesondere diese Aufforderung das
quasi Wagner sich de fact ich auflöst
und die Truppen in die regulären
Streitkräfte integriert werden
Streitkräfte über deren wo bregorian ja
kein Zweifel daran gelassen hat dass er
die verunfähig schlechte ausgerüstet
unmotiviert schlecht geführt hält das
war schon ein Feder
handschuhrichtung Richtung Wagner
geworfen und das hat wie ich das vorhin
dargestellt habe ja aus meiner Sicht
vorläufiger Einschätzung im Grunde
diesen diesen Marsch auch erst ausgelöst
und ich glaube das andere
soll dafür dass er genau beobachten
werden die werden sie behandelt wir sind
sie
geachtet und respektiert auch von den
russischen Streitkräften oder sind sie
sozusagen genau wie Wagner aus Sicht der
regulären Streitkräfte Abschaum und
Kanonenfutter ob es mal drastisch zu
formulieren und so ist es ja einfach gut
Ergebnis gewesen die größten
Opfer haben ja die die ähm die Wagner
selten erbracht also insofern glaube ich
dass jetzt im Krempel fieberhaft darüber
nachgedacht wird wie man mit der
militärischen Führung und mit der
politischen Führung Streitkräfte umgeht
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass schon gut
nicht Verteidigungsminister bleibt
vielleicht auch der Generalstabschef
ausgewechselt wird andere generale
ausgewechselt werden wenngleich Putin ja
schon viele ausprobiert hat also wir
haben ja an der ukrainischen Front schon
eine ganze Reihe von
Personalveränderungen unter den
Generalen gehabt was ja darauf hindeutet
dass putinien ein Stück weit die
Verantwortung gibt ich bin auch der
Meinung dass wir eines Tages Frieden mit
Russland und Friedensverhandlungen mit
Russland haben müssen aber ich sage
ausdrücklich ich glaube nicht dass eines
das solche Verhandlung mit und von
Protein geführt werden können das wird
auch die Ukraine sich nicht bieten
lassen und insofern ist das tatsächlich
Zukunftsmusik ich wünsche mir dass wir
eines Tages Russland ein genauso
großzügiges Angebot der
Wirtschaftskooperationen und der
politischen Zusammenarbeit machen können
wie wir das anderen soweit Republiken
ehemaligen ja erfolgreich getan haben es
gibt da viele Staaten in denen nicht
alles rosig ist wo auch nicht alles
Studenten Manchester
westminster-demokratisch organisiertes
aber in denen die Gefahr der Aggression
gegenüber anderen nicht besteht und auch
eine gute Zusammenarbeit denkbar ist und
so wünsche ich mir das auch mit Russland
Putin hat das nicht gewollt weil Putin
wusste dem Augenblick wo er sich dem
Westen ernährt also in dem es mehr
Zusammenarbeit zum Beispiel mit der EU
gibt dann muss auch die Rechtsordnung
dem Folgen ja jeder Investor aus der
Europäischen Union der unter bestimmten
Bedingungen in Russland investiert fragt
danach wie ist mein Eigentum eigentlich
geschützt vor staatlicher Willkür wo
sind die Gerichte wo ich im Zweifel
recht bekomme wenn ich einmal im Streit
bin mit der mit der Regierung wegen
Genehmigungsverfahren oder
Grundstücksfragen und Putin wusste in
dem Augenblick wo er das zulässt dass
die Kopenhagener Kriterien der EU
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Unabhängigkeit der
Gerichte bei ihnen ähm in Russland Platz
greift ist es mit seiner Herrschaft am
Ende denn das ist ja ein korruptes
kriminelles führungsregime und deswegen
hat er einen dritten Weg versucht der
hat versucht zwischen dem friedlich
automatischen Ansatz des Westens und dem
konservativen Partei
diktaturansatz Chinas einen dritten Weg
zu gehen und meinte er könnte damit
erfolgreicher sein als die EU
Nordamerika oder China und das Ergebnis
ist das Land ist ökonomisch total
zurückgeblieben im Vergleich zu dem was
andere Länder in den letzten 30 Jahren
nach dem Kommunismus auf die Beine
gekriegt haben und keiner will dem
russischen Modell folgen also nicht mal
zentraler zärtlichen Republiken wollen
sich an Russland anschließen oder mit
Russland enger zusammenarbeiten Russland
ist von Putin total isoliert worden im
Übrigen nicht nur gegenüber uns am
besten sondern auch gegenüber Kasachstan
gegenüber Georgien Moldau Ukraine
sowieso
gegenüber anderen Staaten Zentralasiens
der Masterplan von Protein ein dritten
Weg einen erfolgreichen dritten Weg
eines
Nationalstaates eine selbstbewussten
Staates zu haben der ist ähm meines
Erachtens gescheitert und das ist das
größte Dilemma für ihn wenn wir uns an
besonders Putin da jetzt tatsächlich
geschwächt ist wie wir nur von vielen
Seiten beleuchtet haben wie groß ist
denn die Gefahr dass wir hier jetzt in
eine Eskalationsspirale geraten gerade
gegenüber der Ukraine also wenn ich eine
Vorbemerkung machen weil alles was Herr
hart dargelegt ist ich glaube es gehört
auch mit dazu dass wir uns die Frage
stellen müssen kann es sein dass der
West nicht macht das mal ganz allgemein
auch Fehler gemacht hat und ich glaube
er hat war dabei ich war auf jeden Fall
dabei als Putin im Deutschen Bundestag
gesprochen hat und alle Fraktionen im
großen Beifall gezollt haben als er von
einer Friedensordnung von wladioskop bis
Portugal gesprochen hat da gab es
sicherlich nicht nur auf einer Seite
Fehler trotzdem die Beschreibung was
daraus geworden ist die Eskalation
Möglichkeiten die sehe ich weiterhin wir
leben dort insgesamt in einer großen
Gefahr manche machen sich das jetzt zu
leicht und sagen naja der Putin hat ja
gesehen der ist also ganz schwach und
das ist eigentlich am Ende ich glaube
dass das ein falscher Ansatz ist diese
eskalationsmöglichkeiten
sind weiterhin groß und ich will das
noch mal betonen die Reaktion der
westlichen staatenführer von beiden bis
macron einschließlich Scholz die war
angemessen die war zurückhaltend die
sprach von innerrussischen Dingen und
hat weiter danach sich nicht geäußert
ich glaube dass das sehr klug war denn
es ist absolut falsch zu meinen da ist
jetzt kurz wir sind jetzt kurz vorm Ende
ich habe schon erwähnt die nicht ganz
geringen Raketensilos Russlands die es
weiterhin gibt ich will gar nicht die
Atomfrage hier thematisieren aber wir
haben ja bei nur bei der Sprengung des
Staudamms gesehen jetzt mal egal wer es
war also ich weiß das auch noch nicht
bis heute und es äh all die Leute die es
wissen könnten sagen man soll da sehr
vorsichtig sein da haben wir gesehen was
für eine ökologische Katastrophe dort
jetzt läuft wir haben das Atomkraftwerk
wir haben viele andere Dinge wir haben
Schienenwege in der Ukraine die derzeit
nicht angegriffen werden aus guten
Gründen das ist ja kein Zufall darf doch
niemand glauben dass also die Verbindung
von der polnischen Grenze nach Kiew von
Kiew nach Harke das da noch nicht einmal
irgendeine Rakete drauf gefallen es ist
kein Zufall und wir sollten dort schon
sensibel mit umgehen das
Eskalationspotenzial ist weiterhin groß
und ich glaube nicht dass wir auf die
Variante eines abnutzungskrieges setzen
sollten sondern ich würde mir weiterhin
wünschen und vielleicht ist da der
Europäische Rat in der nächsten Woche ja
eine Chance das ist eine europäisch
abgestimmte Friedensinitiative gibt und
das sind keine Vorschriften und
natürlich ist die territoriale
Integrität der Ukraine zu gewährleisten
ohne wenn und aber und trotzdem ist es
zynisch zu sagen lass mal jetzt noch ein
paar Monate weiter kämpfen ich glaube
das ist der falsche Weg er hat wie
würden sie das denn einschätzen glauben
Sie dass es eine Eskalationsspirale gibt
und inwiefern müsste der Westen vor
allen Dingen was das Atomkraftwerke
angeht ganz klare Zeichen aussetzen
ich glaube die Botschaften sind an dem
Punkt klar der amerikanische Präsident
hat ja dazu auch sich geäußert und der
Begriff rote Linien ist ja leider
verbrannt aber ich glaube es ist in
Moskau schon klar das ist bestimmte
Dinge geht über die passieren würden
würde
es seitens des bestens auch ein
stärkeres Eingreifen in dem Krieg geben
ich sehe im Übrigen nicht für Herr Bart
den langen abnutzungskrieg ich glaube
dass die Ukraine tatsächlich im
Augenblick eher die Oberhand hatte und
dass sie im Zeitverlauf tatsächlich die
Chance hat die Territorium zu befreien
und dazu hat sie auch das Recht und ein
Präsident selenski der Ukraine der ja
nun demokratisch gewählt ist und in
Zweifel auch die Unterstützung auf die
Unterstützung des Volkes Wert legt
sozusagen erklären können warum er
gerade jetzt in dieser Situation wo er
Russland offensichtlich ja in
Schwierigkeiten ist plötzlich aufhört zu
kämpfen das Entscheidende bei diesem
Krieg ist ja es geht überhaupt nicht um
Russland es geht nicht um russisches
Territorium niemand zweifelt die
theoretoriale Integrität Russlands in
den Grenzen wie wir sie ja den in der
Karte von Paris zum Beispiel als
unverletzlich anerkannt haben niemand
bezweifelt dass das Russland ein Recht
auf diese territorialen Grenzen hat auch
die Ukraine nicht und es wäre deswegen
das aller einfachste wenn Putin einfach
erklären würde ich substream etwas
satirisch formuliert der Krieg ist
gewonnen wir brauchen jetzt nicht weiter
kämpfen weil die Faschisten in der in
der Ukraine beendet sind und wenn und
deswegen ziehe ich mich zurück
mindestens auf die Linien vor dem 24
Februar mit dem mit der Perspektive im
Zweifel auch über die Krim und die
Ukraine in Gespräche einzutreten und
dann muss man finde ich darüber
nachdenken wenn man mit einer solchen
Entwicklung wird aber so lang Putin
nicht bereit ist seinen seine Truppen
zum Stillstand zu bringen oder gar
zurückzuziehen gibt es keinen Grund
keine Chance für friedensverhandlung was
meiner sichtbar sind dass man die
Ukraine jetzt mit noch mehr Waffen auch
beliefern müsste
ich glaube dass die Ukraine in den
letzten Monaten nachdem Deutschland ja
auch seine Politik in dieser Frage im
übrigen komplett gedreht hat also wir
haben letztes Jahr im Sommer
Diskussionen über Waffensysteme für die
Ukraine geführt wo die Regierung nicht
bereit war die zu liefern die heute
selbstverständlich Tag Vertrag
bereitgestellt werden Flugabwehrsysteme
die hochleistungsfähig sind die
Panzerhaubitzen die glaube ich sehr
wichtig sind in diesem diesen Kampf der
Ukraine der Verteidigungskampf der
Ukraine also insofern tun wir schon viel
ich bin an dem Punkt skeptisch wo wir
sozusagen an die Substanz unserer
Bundeswehr gehen ich glaube dass wir
bestimmte Dinge also zum Beispiel eure
Fighter nicht zur Verfügung stellen
sollten vielleicht auch keine Waffen die
von Eurofightern aus verschlossen werden
können weil wir die im Zweifel ja auch
in Deutschland selbst zu Abschreckung
möglicher Feinde brauchen aber ich
glaube dass wir die Ukraine weiter mit
Munition und Ausrüstung versorgen
sollten so viel wie es geht wir sollten
der deutschen und europäischen
Rüstungsindustrie die Chance Leben zu
liefern was sie liefern kann und wir
sollten die Ukraine so behandeln wie wir
einen nato-staat oder einem der NATO
ähnlich gestellten Staat was Rüstungs
Anlieferungen angeht gestellt haben die
Ukraine hat bisher ihre Zusage keine
Handlungen gegen Russland selbst gegen
das Territorium Russlands vorzunehmen
aus meiner Sicht eingehalten wenn es
dort möglicherweise Angriffe gegeben hat
dann ganz gezielt gegen
Waffen die gegen die Ukraine unmittelbar
eingesetzt wurden ich habe keinen
Zweifel daran dass die das selenski weiß
dass das ganz wichtig ist als ich an
diese Zusage zu halten um den Support
die Unterstützung der westlichen Welt
nicht zu riskieren und insofern habe ich
keine Bedenken jede Granate die wir
entbehren können die die deutsche
Rüstungsindustrie bestätigt bestellen
kann für die panzerplätzen sollte
geliefert werden da will ich zum Schluss
noch mal mein deutlichen Widerspruch
äußern und klar sagen dass die Logik
mehr Waffen schaffen mehr Frieden
überhaupt nicht stimmt ich glaube das
Gegenteil ist der Fall wenn wir in diese
Pädagogik schnellere Lieferung schwerere
Waffen noch mehr Eskalation gehen wird
dieser Krieg eben nicht schneller
beendet werden ich glaube dass die
andere Linie nämlich wirklich auch auf
Verhandlungen zu setzen gestärkt werden
muss da macht Deutschland da macht
Europa zu wenig im Vergleich zu anderen
Staaten und wenn sie sagen Verhandlungen
glauben Sie dass die jetzige Situation
die ja zum Beispiel eine russische Armee
auch viel Chaos verheißt das durch
starke Signale des Westens hier die
Möglichkeit für Verhandlungen geöffnet
werden könnten schauen sie haben die
Situation dass in der vorigen Woche
mehrere afrikanische Staatschefs erst in
Kiel fahren und dann in Moskau war das
ist mehr oder weniger nicht erfolgreich
gewesen wir haben immerhin eine
Situation als ich in Kiel war gerade
eigentlich chinesische Delegation da die
versucht hat mit selenski und Putin zu
vermitteln und ich glaube das Europa
dort eine andere Rolle spielen kann wir
sind die stärksten Industrienationen
gemeinsam mit den Vereinigten Staaten
ich möchte nicht eine Situation dass
alle auf die Wahlen in den Vereinigten
Staaten schauen um zu gucken was
passiert denn da danach mit dem Krieg in
der Ukraine das ist der falsche Weg
sondern Eigenständigkeit Europas sollte
hier auch durch ein konkretes
Verhandlungsangebot vonstatten gehen und
selbstverständlich ist es so ohne die
Unterstützung des Westens wer die
Ukraine nicht mehr und da ist vor allen
Dingen die große humanitäre
Unterstützung in unserem Land da ist die
große finanzielle Unterstützung aktuell
auch militärisch das immer weiter
auszudehnen das sehe ich als falsch an
das habe ich deutlich gesagt ist aber
auch bekannt aber ich habe eine Frage ja
aber er hat das müssen sie ja leider
aushalten dieser Sendung schon weil wir
schon drüber sind und ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich bei Ihnen beiden für das
Gespräch in hat vielen Dank für die
Zuschaltung aus Düsseldorf in der Bart
vielen Dank dass ihr im Studio waren das
war unsere Sendung unter den Linden zur
Situation in Russland das Thema wird uns
sicherlich weiter beschäftigen im Tag
werden Sie über alle aktuellen ähm
verläuft Verläufe noch mal neu
informiert und ich wünsche Ihnen noch
einen schönen Abend bei Phoenix
[Musik]